that question reminds me of a line in
Jesus Christ Superstar which although
it's a kind of a flawed work is one of
my fav one of my favorite Jesus films
we're right towards the end in the song
which is called superstar that lends its
name to the whole thing Judas actually
says to Jesus this is like the kind of
the resurrected sort of Judas he says to
Jesus don't you think it would have been
better if you'd have come in the 20th
century when there is a period of mass
communication when you could have when
you could have spoken to everyone I mean
the interesting thing about it if you
try and conceptualize what must
communication means in the ancient world
one of the best things that you can do
is actually find somewhere a public
place where you can be heard quite
widely and he does get depicted Jesus
does in the New Testament preaching on
the top of mountains and in boats waking
get an audience and when he tries to do
things in houses the houses get crowded
people start taking the roof apart to
try and get to him and this sort of
thing so it does not like at least
within Galilee of his day he was quite a
big thing for a little bit and the word
people you know krause getting to him
but it's it's worth reminding ourselves
they just what a minor blip in terms of
ancient history he made as as a sort of
figure that was in you know was in
Israel at the time because it's only
really as much much later on that
Christianity becomes the force that it
that it eventually becomes it's a very
slow sort of process and it's a process
of you know of disciples and witnesses
and and preaching going on across many
years traveling far and wide me just
think for example of the sheer
difference between Jesus and Paul if the
Gospels are to be trusted Jesus
essentially stays mainly within what we
would call Palestine he's mainly in
Galilee a little bit in Jerusalem he
occasionally kind of moves just outside
of the borders but really doesn't travel
very far and wide for someone who's an
itinerant preacher but then when you get
to Paul Paul travels massively I mean in
a 20-year period he's gone all the way
from Jerusalem to Rome and not just in
one journey but several times he's gone
back to Jerusalem again it's gone back
over the same ground again I mean that
really is is if you want to think about
the skills of ancient communication Paul
definitely had it first of all lowes
nodes of travel secondly getting a few
disciples and people at work with you
that you can send out in in your stead
and thirdly and most importantly of all
he learned the art of writing letters
and I've got those kind of sent around
to brace of his churches where they were
hugely influential